I will never forget how I went to sue  for this magazine and like the  photographer he was just like trying to  get close to me like yeah you want to  get in this magazine and put his oh I  was so mad and this is like this is  crazy how do you handle it I was a  bugging you know what I'm out you know  so crazy I told the magazine owner he is  a Tammy leg so and when I see the me to  move me there's girls from the hood I  know that they went through the same  type of treat me like who make you go  like you gotta do a certain type of  thing for the most boot happens every  day it happens really every day  does it still happen to you at this  point of your career oh hell no I'll put  you on blast on my Instagram I hope  [Music]